I'm with a large group of slow-moving
people and this is really helping me
fidget spinners are not just a cool new
toy they are supposed to be a tool to
help people with ADHD and anxiety focus
I've had ADHD as long as I can remember
people who have a TD when you're not
focused your brain is like going
everywhere
when I saw the fidgets spinner it never
jumped out to me as like something that
would help my ADHD so ADHD can cause
some fidgeting and body control issues
your brain is chronically under aroused
meaning it's kind of bored I'll play
with my hair and I have like split ends
and so it's like a little project really
bad it you know sitting or standing to
watch or you know listen to something
for a long period of time yeah physics
constantly I probably interrupt more
than I fidget I lean back my chair like
this repetitive motions like cracking
knuckles or sitting funny in their chair
or tapping their feet as long as that's
something that functions for them then
it's a fidget that doesn't interfere
with focus it probably actually helps it
the claims that fidget spinners are
backed by science as useful tools for
people with ADHD are somewhat overblown
they keep it vague because there
actually isn't a whole lot to support
these specifically seems like it doesn't
serve many purposes I feel like I would
get after a while like I would get bored
of this I guess I don't really know
until I try
fidget spinners are more likely to be a
distraction and a toy but there are
adults who can make that determination a
little bit better for themselves so if
they are able to get more work done or
they are able to sit through meetings or
get through the tasks in their day and
then I would say that it probably works
I have a lot of work to do today I came
into work early this morning hopefully
this works is it a pie a pie con
Portland's gear if anyone asks I'll just
tell them we're doing an experiment and
hopefully you don't get the shock to
doing stuff like fidgeting around on my
desk
why put my hair up um so that I wouldn't
play with it what am i has the fidgets
spinning annoyed you it's probably
distracted me more than it's haunted
which came out of a meeting with my
favorite spinner and this is a meeting
where shouting out a lot because I won't
pay attention if I don't do that and I
didn't say anything it's a win I'm going
to try to use a fidget spinner while I
watch TV show that is when I tend to
move around a lot when I talk to people
like you know I'll pull it on the star
vision with it and I think it's not well
received by them it's getting kind of
like tedious to use this nice it's like
Shh sand and kind of distracts my brain
and so Ivy's in the budget spinner just
eating graves so I'm sorry I'm not doing
much it does help me focus when I'm
talking about because I know what I'm
doing with my hands often I find myself
in a crowd and I'd be like what I do in
the hands we're about to get on a train
for eight hours the thing keeps spinning
so it's always doing something I really
didn't think if it just when I was going
to work it works I would use the
finished dinner so much and I will put
my hand down and my hand would like get
tingly and it would like need the center
it was crazy
so as the week goes on we're all having
a lot of trouble not losing this thing
it's very loose it'll it never got
permanently lost but sir did you
misplace it probably ever
I had it this morning and Wow oh we're
just going back from a long weekend of
looking at wedding venues and the
fidgets spinner actually was helpful
with my anxiety which was high it didn't
do much for me I saw him with ADHD it
was just another item for me to lose all
the time thought it was gonna be stupid
but it really I really liked it like it
really works the amount this distracts
other people doesn't warrant the amount
it helps me focus I got a bruise here
because I would just like do it so hard
because it was like I just love the
technique just like I thought it was
helping me focus in meetings but maybe
it was just giving me something else to
focus on
so I wasn't so annoying in meeting a
really good test for whether or not a
fidget spinner is something useful being
what did you remember from the meeting
it might be a distraction but it might
not be a an attention focus err and so I
bring it with me but I'd often misplace
it and I think that actually speaks you
know the way that an ADHD brain works
for some people can kind of be another
distraction I was chatting with a whole
bunch of other engineers at the
conference this kind of gave me a little
something to focus on besides the crowd
as I was engaging with other people they
prevented that like brief moment of
boredom that usually leads to getting
distracted with the ADHD my huge issue
is I was always playing with my split
ends like that was really big issue for
me anytime I like kind of felt myself
doing it I would just pick up my fidget
spinner and I would just do this I don't
recommend this for ADHD I recommend it
for anxiety looking at venues and I had
my fidget sputter out every time I heard
a per-person price for food I could have
had a panic attack but I didn't you have
to be in a situation where it's not
annoying people when you're using it and
it's not can work for everyone
but if you want to try it try it